charging is essential to owning an AV
you need it to be able to travel locally
long distances and it's such a part of
our network is making sure that it's a
seamless experience so when you get in
your car you just need to put your
location in the trip planner it
recommends where you need to stop for
how long It prepares your battery it
warms it up so you can make charging
happen faster more efficiently your
Tesla app actually keeps you updated on
the status of your charge session you
just need to park plug in and you can go
about your day it will alert you if your
charge session is coming to an end so
you can maximize your time before you
have to hit the road
[Music]